[Music]
Straight Ahead online crime daily
prosecutors take jurors through another
crime scene in The Pike County Massacre
were you able to say looking at looking
at him there whether he would have been
awake or asleep or is there in a way to
determine that again in my opinion I
would say he was asleep and but Parkland
school shooter penalty phase trial I
find that the prejudice
with the word swastika and the drawings
does not outweigh the probative value
the judge partially grants motions to
introduce certain evidence as the
prosecution prepares to present its
rebutter plus I would like to speak to
the officer in person but what we have
found is we've actually discovered two
dead body 911 calls are released after
two teenagers are found murdered in the
woods of North Carolina and later jury
selection begins in the love triangle
trial of nikisu etzel who faces
conspiracy charges after her husband was
shot to death and burned inside their
home long crime daily covering court
cases from coast to coast
welcome everyone to lawn crime daily I'm
your host Brian buckmeyer week three of
the Pike County Massacre trial begins as
investigators describe yet another crime
scene in The Deadly shootings George
Wagner IV faced his multiple charges
including eight counts of aggravated
murder for his part in the Pike County
massacre in April of 2016 eight members
of the Rodin and Gilly families were
found murdered many as they slept three
children were left alive members of the
Wagner family were arrested in
connection to the murders years later
parents Angela and Billy were arrested
along with Edward Jake Wagner and George
Wagner IV Angela and Jake admitted to
the murders saying they hatched a plan
to be granted full custody of the child
Jake shared with Hannah Rhoden jurors
are now hearing about the murders one
crime scene at a time on Monday
prosecutors focused on new crime scene
where Kenneth Rhoden was found murdered
experts say there was no sign of a
struggle and it appeared as though the
victim was asleep
recalling your bad
time at the scene that day does the
blood flow suggest anything that you
pursue into your training and experience
in my opinion that was the position that
he was shot
were you able to say you're looking at
looking at him there whether he would
have been awake or asleep or is there in
a way to determine that again in my
opinion I would say he was asleep
what was your purpose in taking blind
swabs from our victims hands in this
particular case to see if anybody would
have grabbed or restrained his wrist
during any time in an altercation
and looking at the looking at the scenes
as you saw that day did you see any
signs of a struggle altercation anything
like that no okay
but in such a case though just in case
to be absolutely sure you still take
blind swabs just as a precautionary
measure you get one chance at getting
evidence so
this bcia testimony comes just weeks
after jurors heard the emotional
testimony from Donald Stone the cousin
of Kenneth Rhoden Stone got emotional on
the stand describing what happened when
he found his cousin's dead body
I noticed to the right I didn't see him
in there nowhere so I've seen a Stairway
to the right
and I walked up the stairway
and that's where I found him up there in
his bed
and when you say you found him
can you tell us what condition he found
him in
he had blood over his eyes
and where was he located in his bed
did you believe him to be dead or alive
at that time
good
joining us today is criminal defense
attorney Bernardo villalona and co-host
Terry Austin Bernard Kenneth's cousin
testifies about finding Kenneth's body
then the BCI investigator describes the
crime scene is there a strategy as to
how the prosecution is presenting the
evidence
well what the prosecution is trying to
lay out is as much corroborating
evidence as they can because remember
who's going to testify against the
defendant his mother as well as his
brother so they need to cooperate as
much as they can of their testimony
because when they take the stand first
off they're going to be nervous as to
whether they willingly are going to
fully cooperate and say what happened
and second if they do they need to be
able to corroborate for the jury that
what they're saying is the truth Yeah
the more people are saying the same
thing the tighter the case becomes the
prosecution Terry agent Staley did not
live in the area do you think that makes
a a difference in the overall
investigation
I do I think it might make it a little
bit more difficult if you recall agent
hanshaw who was on the stand for quite
some time he processed that first crime
scene he knew all of the other officers
all of the other agents he was very
particular and then agent Fortner he
processed the second crime scene and he
knew Hinshaw and he actually was able to
use his laser scanner for the first
crime scene so they all worked together
and they knew the area they knew the
neighborhood they knew the people so
agent Stanley I'm certain he did a great
job but he didn't know everyone he
didn't know the area and he didn't know
the other agent so I just think that if
he had been in the area he could
probably process that scene a little bit
better a little faster it's something
the cross could probably focus on as far
as some weaknesses in the case but as it
turns out I think he picked up the
evidence he processed it he did a good
job and they needed him they needed
people from outside the area because so
many people had died
yeah maybe it kind of speaks to the
atrocities that this community is facing
that the murders were so huge and so big
a number and scale they needed people
from outside the community to help well
we'll see what the jury does that
information from the Pike County
Massacre to the Doomsday cult Duo I said
Idaho judge bans cameras from the
upcoming trial of Lori valo dabel and
her husband Chad Seventh District Judge
Stephen Boyce made the ruling on Friday
citing that news organizations will no
longer be able to take pictures or
videos inside the courtroom in this case
and that he feared the images could
prevent a fair trial last month Lori
valo day Bells attorney asked the judge
to bend camos from the courtroom after
they say one news organization abused
the privilege by repeatedly zooming in
on Valor dabel's face during an August
hearing at the time valo Dabo made
headlines for smiling during her hearing
valo Debo and her husband are charged
with conspiring to kill valo Debo's
youngest two children and Chad dabel's
late former wife both have pled not
guilty to charges which carry a
potential death penalty
still had on Law and crime daily the
Chile 911 call released after two North
Carolina teens are found murdered but
first the Parkland school shooter days
before the prosecution begins its
rebuttal case the judge makes a ruler on
what evidence can be included
[Music]
welcome back as the prosecution prepares
for its rebuttal case the judge makes a
Monumental ruling on evidence in the
Parkland school shooter penalty phase
trial after pleading guilty to 17 counts
of murder and 17 more counts of
attempted murder the shooter now faces a
sentence of life in prison or the death
penalty weeks after the prosecution
motioned to include controversial
evidence judge Elizabeth schreird ruled
partially in their favor according to
court documents the judge noted that
while some material may be prejudicial
it is relevant in rebuttal to a key
issue of the defendant's mental health
diagnosis that means prosecutors can
include images of swastikas on the
defendant's AR-15 and boots they can
also include 20 examples of the
defendant discussing hate speech racism
animal abuse or child pornography on the
internet that number is down from more
than 400 examples of the defendant's
search history on Tuesday jurors are due
back in court as the prosecution is
expected to begin its follow the case
Terry do you agree with the judge in
what is and is not coming in
I do Brian I definitely think she made
the right decision here and I think she
was very careful to carve out just
exactly what can and cannot come in the
swastikas like she said they're relevant
because they do go to show his mental
health and it shows the hatred that he
harbored so I definitely think that they
should come in and frankly they were on
the boots and they were on the gun the
boots and the gun were at the scene at
the crime that should be shown and I
think that the other you know derogatory
comments the racial slurs that should
also come in because again it's
definitely showing his mental health his
State of Mind the fact that he had
hatred in his heart and that goes to
damages and she was correct when she
didn't let hundreds of pictures and
other things on social media in but she
did let you know dozens in it's gonna
answer the question as to whether or not
any of it is redundant and I think
that's going to help the prosecution the
prosecution doesn't want the jury to get
bored so even though she limited I think
it's going to be helpful to the
prosecutor Fusion yeah I would agree I
don't see any of this being helpful to
defense but let's ask Bernardo how much
will these images change the direction
of the trial and will it greatly damage
the defense's case
I think it definitely changes the
direction of the trial because remember
the juror the jury they want to know why
how can a man shoot 34 people killing 17
of those people and now you're giving
them a why a why that they did not know
at the beginning of the case during the
prosecution's case and doing the defense
case and they're not going to hear until
now the rebuttal it makes you look at
Nicholas Cruz completely different
because now you know that he has more
hate in his heart and that he's been
looking into all this different type of
hate especially to the point where he's
walking around with a firearm that has a
swastika system on it as well as his
shoes so it definitely changes the
perspective of how you view this case
and how you view Nicholas Cruz yeah
we'll see that perspective as it changes
in Morris as the jury does get to hear
the case on Tuesday in the federal court
Elizabeth Holmes's sentencing is delayed
until October as her Team Works to score
her a new trial prosecutors those say
their reasoning is not grounds to have a
conviction thrown out as long crime
daily reported a former theranos
employee who testified against Holmes
showed up at her home in the weeks
before sentencing defense attorneys say
that's grounds for a new trial but
prosecutors disagree an emotion filed
earlier this month defense attorneys say
former lab director Adam rosendorf went
to Holmes's house last month after
requesting a meeting with her lawyer
rosendorf allegedly met and had a
conversation with Holmes's partner
William Evans in their driveway
expressing regret over his testimony
however in a sworn declaration rosendorf
stood by his testimony and refuted the
defense's assertion that the government
did anything more than encourage him to
tell the truth Elizabeth Holmes was
convicted earlier this year on three
counts of wire fraud and one count of
conspiracy to commit wire fraud she's
due back in court on October 3rd for a
hearing to discuss Holmes's motion for a
new trial right now she is scheduled to
be sentenced on October 17th
coming up on Law and crime daily after
multiple delays a North Dakota woman
accused of conspiring to murder her
husband is heading to try plus a North
Carolina Sheriff's Office releases the
19.1 calls in the deaths of two
teenagers who were found murdered will
have what the caller said on the other
side of the break
[Music]
welcome back we head to North Carolina
where officials released 911 calls in
the murder case in which two teenagers
were found shot to death last weekend 18
year old Devin Clark and a 14 year old
lyric Woods went missing Friday
September 16th two days later the high
school students were found shot to death
along a hiking trail by men riding ATVs
in the area investigators believe us 17
year old was responsible that teenager
whose name is not being released due to
their age faces two counts of
first-degree murder in a juvenile
summons in the shooting deaths of the
two victims in North Carolina's 16 and
17 year olds who commit crimes are not
automatically charged as adults but the
case could be transferred if there's
probable cause officials have released
the 911 calls from when Clark and woods
were discovered
Orange County 9-1-1 what's the address
of the emergency
I guess the officers probably need to
respond non-emergency but it is a pretty
serious issue
um I would like to speak to the officer
in person
um but what we have found is we've
actually discovered two dead bodies
what's the address as to where you found
the bodies
there's not an address
it's kind of there's no house where we
found the bodies exactly where are the
bodies
um it's there's a there's a power
there's a like a
and there's an accident
like where the power company kind of
rode in
um
what does a prosecution get from the 911
call that could lead to a conviction
well fortunately that person did come
across the bodies because they were only
there for two days if it had been much
longer some of that evidence might have
disintegrated but they couldn't provide
an address but they did take the
authorities back to those bodies
apparently if it was a boy or girl I
don't know because the voice has been
changed it leads me to believe that it's
a young person and they had to go home
to the father to say what should I do
and the father said call 9-1-1 and then
they directed them back to the scene so
the good news is someone found the
bodies the bad news is it's not it
doesn't seem a lot of evidence on that
scene just yet or we haven't heard any
of the evidence reported whether or not
the bodies were dragged whether or not
they were walking out there whether or
not there were you know tracks from
tires so we'll learn all that
information but I think the best thing
that we know right now from that caller
is they found those bodies yeah and
exactly when and what time they found it
as well Bernardo the suspect is uh who's
going to be charged as a juvenile at
first we hear that it could change to
being an adult so what do you think is
going to happen when the suspect is
found charged as juvenile or as an adult
well given that we're talking about two
homicides the whoever the person is that
is found it's going to be charged as an
adult given the violence that occurred
in order to lead to these deaths so you
know even in New York so you can be
arrested as a juvenile but when you're
talking about certain acts of violence
they make an application to the court to
actually charge the juvenile as an adult
and prosecute them as an adult which
changes the whole scheme of things in
terms of what type of sentence you can
get if you are convicted yeah and even
in New York that really comes down to
often how you brandish your weapon and
use it violently I would assume in a
case like this as you said Bernard a
double homicide probably charged as an
adult
when we come back it's North Dakota
versus Nikki suenson we break down long
crime networks and newest Live Trial as
Enzo stands trial in connection with the
murder of her husband
[Music]
welcome back to lawn crime daily new
details released in the Christmas smart
murder trial reveal one of the
defendant's attorneys may have been
working on a plea deal the trial of
Father and Son and Paul and Ruben Flores
in is underway in Salinas California
prosecutors say Paul was the last person
seen with smart who disappeared in 1996.
they say his father Reuben helped
conceal Smart's body she was legally
declared dead in 2002 newly unsealed
documents show Paul flores's attorney
may have been working on a plea deal
back in 2010. the court documents reveal
Paul Flores attorney told investigators
his client could lead officials to
Smart's body in exchange for a plea deal
more documents reveal allegations
against Paul Flores of sexual assault
rape videos and child pornography
and in North Dakota jury selection
begins in the love triangle murder trial
of Nikki suenzel who was charging
connection to the 2019 murder of her
husband investigators allege Ensel was
having an affair with a man named Earl
Howard while she was still married to
her husband Chad in late December of
2019 officials believe Ansel and Howard
conspired to kill Chad after filing a 26
thousand dollar property insurance
policy on the home she shared with her
husband in the early morning hours of
December 31st Ensel and Howard allegedly
shot and killed Chad in the master
bedroom of the home with a shotgun Days
Later firefighters and police responded
to ensels calling 9-1-1 about a fire at
the home investigators believe the two
started the fire to cover up evidence
and burn Chad's body police couldn't
determine if it was Enzo or Howard that
pulled the triggered killing Chad so
they were both charged with conspiracy
to commit murder among other charges
Howard pled guilty to conspiracy and
arson charges and was sentenced to 25
years a jury of 12 along with four
alternates will be selected to hear
ensel's case
we're out of opening statements haven't
begun yet but what do you think the
defense in this case is and is it
believable
well the defense in the opening
statements should make no promises to
this jury I think they need to keep it
very general in saying that keep an open
mind do not make a decision wait until
all the evidence and lack of evidence
has been presented and wait until after
closing arguments and jury instructions
before they can sit down and make a
final determination in this case if you
keep it simple and just say that the
prosecution has to meet their burden of
proven that case Beyond A Reasonable
Doubt and that their client is presumed
to be innocent I think you leave
yourself open for so much possibility
and so much different trial advantages
doing the trial where you're not
committed to just one strategy
absolutely the conspiracy aspect of it
really intrigues me because the
prosecution we don't know who killed
them but we're not charging anyone with
killing just conspiracy Terry Love
Triangle convicted boyfriend and a 26
000 insurance policy is this a strong
case for the prosecution murder for
money and love perhaps you bet it is no
question about it Brian and for all of
the reasons you just stated there's a
motive here that love triangle there's
the money motive and even though 26 000
is not a lot we have seen that people
have killed for less and they have the
opportunity here they have access to
that home it's his wife they are in the
house together she could do it at any
point in time and they have the means so
they have the motive the opportunity and
the means apparently they had a gun or
whatever they had was able to you know
shoot and kill him and they started the
fire allegedly to cover it up so I think
the charges that are pending now against
her could actually be higher and I think
there should be more evidence to say
there was actual murder not just
conspiracy to commit the murder
conspiracy to commit arson and
conspiracy camper they have more I think
all right well this is another live
tried the long crime network will be
following make sure to check it out
thank you for joining us here on Law and
crime daily we'll see you next time as
we discuss Justice in America
[Music]
[Music]
foreign
[Music]